cybersecurity experts say North Korea
may be to blame for the unprecedented
global ransomware attack this is new
information the hacking has crippled
computer systems in at least 150
countries since Friday experts say that
the digital fingerprints resemble other
attacks mounted by North Korea Adriana
Diaz is in Beijing with why the threat
may not be over
Adriana good morning good morning
cyber security firms have found
similarities between the tools used in
this attack and those used in previous
hacks blamed on North Korea
they were first developed by the
National Security Agency but stolen and
leaked and may have ended up in the
hands of North Korean hackers just as
North Korea boasted about the successful
launch of a nuclear capable rocket
technology experts say they have
evidence North Korean hackers could be
behind another international threat last
Friday's global cyber attack Gregory
Clark is CEO of Symantec one of the
computer security firms that made the
North Korea connection in this case
there is a fragment of the technology
that was associated with Lazarus the
Lazarus group is a hacker collective
with ties to North Korea and Symantec
discovered portions of its malware codes
in wanna cry the hacking program used in
last weekend cyber attacks Lazarus was
also implicated in the 2014 Sony
Pictures data hack in apparent
retaliation for its release of the film
the interview that mocked North Korean
leader Kim jong-un and it was connected
with last year's theft
of 81 million dollars from a Bangladesh
account at the Federal Reserve Bank in
New York US officials blamed both hacks
on North Korea the latest attack was
widespread forcing a shutdown of
hospitals and other businesses around
the world it exploited a known
vulnerability in an older Microsoft
program encrypting files to make them
inaccessible until a ransom of three
hundred dollars was paid while
technology experts were able to contain
this weekend's attack the threat is not
yet over and we're worried about the
smart guys realizing what worked what
didn't
and something else coming our way that
that might be a little bit better
engineered after that happened the
European police agency says that roughly
63 thousand dollars has already been
paid to the hackers by people with
infected computers now experts say it's
still too early to blame it on North
Korea because the culprits may have just
used the lazarus malware perhaps to make
it look like a North Korean attack Gail
thank you very much Adriana Diaz
reporting from Beijing